[Au Liban, il est connu comme le loup blanc, son nom : Michel Eléftériadès. C'est le patron du Music Hall, l'un des hauts lieux de la vie nocturne à Beyrouth,
il est aussi producteur, businessman, agitateur politique. Un personnage mystérieux mais aussi très influent, rencontre avec le maître des soirées libannaises endiablées...]
[Il a surtout une histoire comme souvent, les hommes caractérisés comme cela, ils ont une vie derrière eux.
Le cas de Michel, c'est qu'il a eu une vie. Il a toujours été résistant, il a même combattu, il n'était pas toujours du bon côté (c'est-à-dire celui qui gagnait), mais il était résistant.
Chaque fois que l'on me parle du Liban, je demande des nouvelles de ce phénomène Eléftériadès, pour savoir ce qu'il devient...]
[J'ai fait donc cet éloge du militant, du militant de base qu'il a été, du musicien, de l'écrivain, l'homme amateur des beaux-arts aussi, de peintures,
mais je crois aussi que c'est plus que cela et que certainement, dans le Liban qui vient, il devrait occuper une place plus grande.
Je pense que Michel Eléftériadès fait partie de ces personnes que si elles n'existaient pas, il faudrait les inventer.
Je dirais de lui que c'est véritablement un cosmopolite au sens le plus noble du terme, un internationaliste qui en a eu assez de cette division de l'humanité...]
Hello Thinkerview ! Je réponds à vos questions depuis mon lougne, le Utopia Now, en plein coeur de Beyrouth, la capitale du Liban.
On ne peut plus parler du poids de la parole diplomatique française au moyen-orient. Elle n'existe plus. C'est la parole américaine.
Ils sont devenus des portes-parole de la parole américaine, c'est devenu de tout petits pions,
des poissons-pilote qui naviguent avec le grand requin dans l'espoir de recueillir des miettes. C'est vraiment pathétique. La France avait un grand rôle dans cette région du monde.
La diplomatie française a eu son heure de gloire, c'était une référence dans la diplomatie mondiale. C'est devenu maintenant, comme disait mon ami Jacques Vergès, la "putain des américains".
Ce qui s'est passé en Syrie récemment a été une grande humiliation pour les Etats-Unis et ses alliés. Je ne sais pas comment ils vont pouvoir justifier toute cette excitation,
tous ces préparatifs pour partir en guerre et puis du jour au lendemain, après que l'ours russe ait montré ses dents, ils se sont soudain assagis,
c'est devenu soudain des grandis, des gens qui parlent de dialogue, qui veulent une solution pacifique pour la crise en Syrie.
Donc je ne sais pas comment être crédible après un tel virement.
La politique étrangère de la France est une politique mercenaire. La France ne peut plus vivre comme à l'époque du colonialisme.
Elle n'a plus de colonies qui peuvent lui permettre de vivre dans l’opulence. Les français devraient travailler plus. Ils devraient respecter les investisseurs.
Ils devraient créer un système qui respecte les ambitieux. Quand on parle à longueur de journée de "petit, petit, petit"
en parlant du café, de la sortie, du dîner, de la... tout, la culture du "petit", on ne peut pas exiger du grand et vouloir vivre comme des nababs.
Maintenant, ils essaient le néocolonialisme. Au lieu de partir eux-même en guerre, ils envoient des armes rouillées à des proxys.
A des mercenaires qui font la guerre à leur place, dans l'espoir qu'une fois ces mercenaires au pouvoir, ils vont pouvoir rafler des contrats pour reconstruire le pays,
pour exploiter les ressources naturelles de ces pays ; c'est ce qu'ils ont fait un peu avec la Libye. Ils ont pensé qu'ils peuvent faire bon usage de ce système,
et essayer de l'utiliser ailleurs. Mais la Syrie n'est pas la Libye. Ce qui peut être valable dans un pays où l'armée n'est pas une vraie armée,
ne peut pas être appliqué dans des pays qui ont de vraies armées, qui ont des gens qui analysent mieux ce qui se passe.
Et on "on peut tromper quelques-uns quelques fois mais on ne peut pas tromper tout le monde tout le temps".
C'est-à-dire qu'ils peuvent le faire une ou deux fois. Mais la troisième ou quatrième fois ça devient un peu difficile à faire passer la chose.
Même si le clown Bernard-Henri Lévy fait des prouesses incroyables sur des chaînes internationales pour expliquer que Bachar El-Assad est un islamiste dangereux,
même s'il va faire de grands discours sur les valeurs de sa "philosophie humaniste", il n'est plus crédible. Il est complètement grillé.
Et c'est dommage que la France qui a de grands philosophes encore aujourd'hui et qui a eu des philosophes qui ont changé l'histoire de l'humanité,
c'est dommage qu'elle accepte que quelqu'un comme Bernard-Henri Lévy puisse encore passer sur des chaînes internationales avec en dessous "french philosopher".
Donc ça c'est une honte pour l'histoire de la philosophie française et pour la culture française en général.
En général je suis contre l'impérialisme qui découle des superpuissances. La Russie en est une.
Mais quand je compare la situation actuelle à la situation de l'uni-polarité américaine que l'on a vécue les dernières 20-30 années,
je préfère avoir une Russie forte avec un nouveau Tsar, avec quelqu'un qui sait imposer sa volonté. Ça limite les dégâts.
Le pouvoir absolu corrompt absolument. Les Etats-Unis étaient devenus très arrogants parce qu"ils savaient qu'ils pouvaient partir là où ils veulent,
sans jamais avoir de comptes à rendre. Qu'ils pouvaient faire les erreurs qu'ils peuvent faire, sans être punis.
Et ça c'est très dangereux parce que des millions de morts sont appelés "collateral damages", donc pour eux ça n'est pas grand chose,
mais pour nous qui vivons dans cette région du monde, c'est nos familles, c'est nos amis, ce sont des vies entières qui sont broyées.
Et ils l'ont fait. Ils l'ont fait à plusieurs reprises et voulaient continuer à le faire jusqu'à ce que la Russie et Poutine vienne leur dire "Non."
Poutine est un grand leader. Ca fait longtemps que le monde n'a pas connu de vrai grand leader. La France avait eu une tradition de chefs d'état de grande culture,
qui avaient du charisme, qui avaient du talent, qui avaient du style. Mais maintenant c'est vraiment des médiocres.
Là on a eu deux médiocres... Pas "on" mais les Français ont eu... Je me sens un peu français quelque part vu que ma culture et mes lectures sont françaises.
C'est triste que la France n'ait pas son Poutine qui pourrait redorer un peu le blason de la France.
C'est triste de voir un chef d'état français qui ne sait pas marcher sur un tapis et qu'une femme doit remettre dans la bonne direction.
C'est triste de voir un chef français qui ne ressemble à rien, qui n'a même pas compris qu'il y avait un accord qui était en train d'être signé entre les Russes et les Américains.
Et qui, même quand les Américains avaient rappelé leurs cerbères, lui était toujours là à aboyer, encore tout excité. C'est vraiment triste pour la France et c'est par amour de la France que je le dis.
On ne peut pas parler d'une perception unifiée dans la région. Quand une décision russe est applaudie par une partie de la population moyen-orientale,
il y a l'autre partie qui la maudit et vice-versa. Il y a deux axes actuellement : il y a un axe russe, chinois, iranien, plusieurs partie d'Amérique latine,
et dans la région, il y a des gens qui adhèrent à cet axe. Il y a l'autre axe où il y a les Etat-Unis, Israël, la France, l'Angleterre et des pays comme ça.
Donc partout dans le monde, il y a un fort clivage entre ces deux axes et leurs partisans.
Sous prétexte de démocratie, l'occident est en train d'armer et de porter son appui à des hordes barbares qui pratiquent le cannibalisme,
qui pratiquent des comportements médiévaux, parfois même encore plus anciens, des choses de la guerre du feu.
Des coupeurs de tête sévissent en Syrie, ils appliquent ce qu'eux appellent la Charia, qui n'a rien à voir avec la vrai Charia islamique.
Ce sont des malades qui viennent du monde entier pour détruire une civilisation magnifique qui a survécu à plein d'invasions et qui est arrivée intacte jusqu'à nous.
Je parle de villages comme Haloula où l'araméen, la vraie langue du christ, est encore parlée.
Et ces gens-là vont en quelques mois, détruire cet héritage, soutenus par l'occident sous prétexte de démocratie.
On nous parle de démocratie, on parle d'établir une démocratie en Syrie alors qu'ils sont alliés de l'Arabie Saoudite, du Qatar,
de plein de pays qui n'ont rien à voir avec la démocratie.
La Syrie n'était pas Byzance, la Syrie n'est pas la Suède, la Syrie de Assad ; mais au moins c'est un pays où il y avait les droits de la femme,
où les minorités pouvaient vivre bien, les minorités religieuses, sexuelles et autre. Où il y avait une classe moyenne. Où l'on pouvait parler un temps soit peu de politique.
On n'a pas le droit d'insulter le président mais il y a plein de pays et de démocraties et de grands pays ayant une grande culture, de tolérance et de parole libre,
qui ne tolèrent pas et n'acceptent pas d'insulter les chefs d'état. Donc la Syrie n'était pas un despotisme tel qu'on essaie de le dépeindre maintenant.
Et même si ça avait été le cas, on ne peut pas sous prétexte de faire tomber un régime qui n'est pas très démocratique,
faire alliance avec des sauvages, avec des gens tels qu'on voit maintenant en Syrie.
Je suis contre toutes les interventions. Je pense qu'un pays, un peuple qui ne peut pas lui-même se libérer, un peuple qui ne peut pas lui-même faire sa révolution,
ne mérite pas d'être aidé. Un peuple qui ne sait pas respecter une file, se mettre en ligne...
Quand on voit en Syrie ou dans plein de pays arabes, on voit que OK, ils se mettent en ligne mais elle est horizontale la ligne, au lieu d'être verticale.
C'est-à-dire qu'il faut commencer par éduquer les peuples avant de leur donner le droit au vote.
Ça fait des années que je dis que si demain, il y a des élections dans le monde arabe, ce sont les islamistes qui vont prendre le pouvoir.
Il faut commencer par aider les peuples à travers la culture. La culture est primordiale. Ceux qui préparent la culture, ce sont des philosophes, des écrivains, des intellectuels,
qui peuvent créer chez les peuples, une conscience... Qui peuvent installer une conscience qui prépare les révolutions.
Dans des révolutions dans cette partie du monde, ceux qui vont voter, ils vont écouter la parole du cheikh,
et même pour les chrétiens de l'autre région, c'est aussi la parole du curé. Or les curés et les cheikhs n'ont jamais mené très loin, ce sont les philosophes,
ce sont des gens qui ont une plus grande ouverture d'esprit qui peuvent mener les peuples vers des démocraties à la scandinave ou à l'européenne,
ou à des démocraties où il y a le respect de l'individu, il y a le respect de la diversité, de l'autre mais si c'est la parole du cheikh et la parole du curé, bonjour la nouvelle constitution !
A mon avis, il n'y a plus d'intervention directe occidentale en Syrie. Et même à l'époque où...
Je suis très ami avec des gens des Nations Unies, des gens très haut-placés et j'étais à un débat où ils voulaient savoir s'il fallait évacuer
au Liban ou non parce qu'il y avait tous ces préparatifs de guerre américaine et j'insistais et ai parié avec eux qu'il n'y aura pas de frappe américaine.
Personne ne peut supporter ça, aucun chef occidental ne peut prendre le risque maintenant, de le faire. De déclencher une 3ème guerre mondiale.
Je connais bien les Russes, j'ai vécu un peu là-bas et je sais que quand un président russe dit "Niet", ça veut dire "Niet". Ça n'est pas "On verra" et "Peut-être"...
Donc ils ne peuvent pas le faire. Les conséquences auraient été désastreuses ; on a vu déjà le résultat en Irak, en Syrie ça aurait été encore pire.
Et pas que la Syrie, quand je dis la Syrie, ça aurait été le Liban aussi et ça aurait embrasé toute la région. Donc je pense qu'on a évité le pire.
J'espère qu'en Syrie, ça ne va pas être une guerre de longue durée, ce qu'on appelle "low intensity conflict" qui peut durer très longtemps,
ça n'est pas une vraie guerre mais des bandes Mad-max qui se déplacent et qui sèment la terreur, qui brûlent des villages, qui violent, qui coupent des têtes,
qui font des délires... Et ils sont très difficiles à éliminer parce qu'ils continuent à venir. Ils viennent de tout le monde arabo-musulman,
et c'est un réservoir illimité. Ca peut faire l'affaire de plusieurs pays d'envoyer chez le charcutier tout ce stock de potentiels terroristes,
mais ça coûte très cher à la Syrie, au Liban aussi et à tous les pays de la région.
J'espère que la Russie va pouvoir imposer, qu'elle a assez de cartes pour pouvoir faire pression et arrêter ce délire en Syrie.
Je pense qu'Assad ne peut pas revenir à la légitimité qu'il avait avant les évènements en Syrie, il va devoir faire des concessions,
c'est le cas dans toutes les négociations : les deux parties sont appelées à faire des petites concessions et je pense qu'en faisant de petites concessions
et en trouvant une sorte de scénario, de nouveaux pactes, ils peuvent reconstruire la Syrie. Il y a des gens à exclure, ceux qui ont détruit leur pays
et qui ont été des mercenaires à la solde des monarchies du pétrodollar ou bien des puissances étrangères n'ont pas leur place dans le nouveau pays.
Ca va mettre du temps mais je suis plutôt optimiste.
Le flux des réfugiés syriens au Liban est une vraie catastrophe pour le Liban.
C'est-à-dire qu'une population de 3 millions - 3.5 millions de libanais ne peut pas accueillir 2 millions de réfugiés.
C'est un tout petit pays, c'est à peine un département français et tout à coup, il y a 2 millions de réfugiés démunis qui débarquent dans ce département.
C'est inconcevable, c'est une catastrophe qu'aucun autre pays n'aurait pu assimiler.
Il y a ce côté miracle libanais, cette force, cette résillience des libanais, cette capacité à absorber les chocs mais il ne faut pas exagérer.
Il faut que le monde entier, surtout que ceux qui se considèrent comme les amis du peuple syrien et ceux qui veulent le bien de la Syrie
se penchent sur ce problème et viennent en aide à ces réfugiés à travers le Liban.
Parce que c'est nous qui sommes en train de payer avec notre économie, avec notre bien-être, on a déjà assez payé.
On a déjà eu 15 ans ce guerre civile. La Syrie avait pris part dans cette guerre civile contre les libanais.
Donc quand ils ont, quand ça se passe bien pour eux, c'est l'armée syrienne qui envahit le Liban et quand ils ont des problèmes, c'est le réfugiés syriens qui viennent nous envahir.
Donc le discours peut paraître un peu nationaliste, il peut déranger les vierges éfarouchées des bons sentiments et de l'humanitaire et de ce qu'il faut faire et pas faire.
Mais je suis en train d'être réaliste. J'aime bien mon frère, mais s'il vient avec toute sa famille dans ma maison, qu'il veut dormir dans mon lit,
et s'il veut me bousiller ma vie, je lui dis non. Il y a des limites. Un invité, un réfugié se doit d'être un peu plus discret, un peu moins envahissant.
C'est pas la peine de venir avec les 2-3 voitures de la famille, c'est pas la peine de rouler... Parce qu'on a des embouteillages monstre !
On est un pays de services. On a pas de campagnes avec des paysans qui sont en train de la cultiver,
et qui aident notre économie, on a pas de grande industrie, on est basés sur des services.
On peut plus avoir un meeting, on ne peut plus envoyer un papier à signer d'un endroit à l'autre, on ne peut plus rien faire.
Le moindre trajet qui prenait 2-3 minutes prend maintenant 1 heure. Donc c'est vraiment une situation alarmante.
Et le problème c'est que chaque fois que j'en parle, c'est le lever de bouclier, c'est les insultes...
J'ai de très bonnes relations avec l'armée libanaise. Dans ce lieu même chaque semaine, je rencontre des dizaines d'officiers.
Je pense que l'espoir du Liban passe par l'armée libanaise, que l'armée libanaise peut vraiment faire un changement
pour le Liban, que dans un pays aussi pourri, où il y a autant de corruption, où il y a autant de communautés, où il n'y a plus de repères,
l'armée peut jouer un grand rôle. J'ai lancé une campagne de soutien à l'armée libanaise.
J'ai demandé que l'armée libanaise prenne le pouvoir. Je ne suis pas... Ce n'est pas par amour de l'armée en général, ce n'est pas dogmatique comme approche.
C'est réaliste, c'est un peu aussi égoïste, parce que je connais... Mon intérêt est l'intérêt des libanais.
L'armée libanaise est la seule qui peut garantir la survie du Liban avec tous les conflits qui sont autour du Liban.
C'est un petit pays qui peut être facilement contrôlé, qu'on peut diriger comme une forteresse.
On peut appeller ça un coup d'état mais il y a une forme de coup d'état qui est la plus acceptée par tout le monde
qui est le coup d'état gardien, c'est quand des officiers qui prennent le pouvoir non pas par amour du pouvoir ou pour leur propre intérêt,
mais qui veulent protéger ce pays, qui veulent être les gardiens de cet héritage, de ce que nos parents nous ont laissés.
Pour le passer aux générations futures, peut-être pas les générations mais dans 10 ans. C'est-à-dire protéger le pays,
travailler sur les institutions, préparer une nouvelle génération de gens à travers une nouvelle culture, une nouvelle approche,
imposer un livre commun d'histoire, calmer le clergé musulman, chrétien, enfin toute forme de clergé, limiter l'action des religieux.
Et préparer un nouveu pays. Ca prendra le temps qu'il faut et l'armée donnera de nouveau le pays aux gens.
Il faut aussi calmer les média parce que la liberté d'expression, c'est bien. Mais ça ne donne pas le droit à dire n'importe quoi.
Il y a des limites. Or les libanais et plein de pays arabes pensent que la liberté d'expression c'est le droit à l'insulte,
c'est le droit au prosélytisme, à l'incitation raciale, à l'incitation religieuse, or non.
L'armée doit prendre le pouvoir, l'armée doit pouvoir tout contrôler, si l'on veut que le Liban existe toujours.
Le Nowheristan est un projet culturel, social, politique, philosophique et autres.
C'est un projet qui offre des solutions à plein de problèmes qu'on pensait sans solution. Des solutions faciles.
C'est une idée qui bien sûr peut s'apparenter à l'utopie, qui est une utopie actuellement. Mais je pense que tout progrès,
à travers l'histoire de l'humanité à commencé par être une utopie. Et les grands pas de l'humanité,
c'était la réalisation de ces utopies. Ca devient de plus en plus facile maintenant, de communiquer un nouveau projet.
Le temps du Nowheristan est vraiment venu, il y a plein de gens qui sont dégoutés par les politiciens,
par la manière dont le monde est dirigé, et qui pensent que l'on peut maintenant rêver et travailler pour la réalisation d'un projet comme le Nowheristan.
Donc ça peut avoir plusieurs noms mais j'ai choisi ce nom parce qu'il a un côté amusant, un côté ludique
et je pense que c'est pas mal de présenter une idée qui est très sérieuse, qui est béton, mais avec une approche un peu plus légère.
C'est beaucoup mieux que de faire ce que font les autres politiciens, c'est-à-dire servir de la merde mais dans un packaging très sérieux.
Donc il vaut mieux attirer les jeunes, ne pas faire un truc complètement hermétique, exposer d'une manière simple
et non pas simpliste, de manière simple des idées complexes, des idées sérieuses, des idées qui découlent de beaucoup d'expériences et de philosophie.
Plutôt que de faire ce que font d'autre politiciens c'est-à-dire que je vois parfois des discours de politiciens,
où ils parlent, ils présentent très bien, ils savent très bien parler, ils ont appris le body-language avec des spécialistes,
et ils sont très bien habillés mais ils disent n'importe quoi. C'est-à-dire quand on analyse, quand on fait une saisie de ce qu'ils ont dit
et qu'on lit le contenu de ce qu'ils ont dit, ça ne veut vraiment rien dire et ce truc dans les débats présidentiels où ça devient ridicule
parce que c'est un concours de qui a la meilleure mémoire : 2.34% des gens pensent que ... et l'autre lui dit non c'est 2.36% ...
Mais on s'en fout de tout ça. Ca c'est des détails qui n'ont aucun sens parce que maintenant je vais sur mon ordinateur,
je tape sur Google, je googlise n'importre quelle statistique et je trouve tout, je n'ai pas besoin d'un perroquet qui vient me les répéter à la télévision,
je n'ai pas besoin d'élire quelqu'un qui a une bonne mémoire, ou quelqu'un qui a ... J'ai besoin de gens qui appportent des solutions.
Or, tous ces gens-là, tous ces grands chef de partis européens et ces chefs d'état n'apportent rien.
Mais vraiment rien. Et c'est pour ça qu'il y a une sorte de no-future chez la jeunesse européenne. Ils sont désabusés.
Ils ont 20 ans et ils sont là à penser le pourcentage qu'ils auront à la retraite dans 40 ans, ils sont là à faire des manifs pour des trucs mesquins.
Mais c'est pas ça qui va changer le monde, c'est pas ça qui va changer le avie des gens, il faut que les gens réalisent qu'ils peuvent exiger un grand changement.
La campagne d'Obama c'était "changement" mais c'était rien, c'est des changements minimes, c'est blanc bonnet et bonnet blanc.
C'est exactement la même politique qu'ils continuent à faire mais sous des slogans qui sont plus intelligents.
Parce qu'il est plus intelligent que le cow-boy qu'il y avait avant lui, c'est difficile d'être plus con que George W. Bush.
Donc c'est pas parce qu'il est un peu plus intelligent qu'on devrait s'extasier, ou que les américains doivent se contenter d'un tel changement,
c'est pas parce qu'il est un peu plus basané que le Yankee qu'il y avait avant lui qu'on doit dire que c'est la victoire du rêve de Martin Luther King.
C'est pas ça dont parlait Martin Luther King, c'est pas de prendre un noir... Il n'est pas noir américain, c'est un métisse...
Afro-américain qui est devenu président. C'était pas ça la vitoire des noirs, quand on voit dans les villes américaines maintenant,
on peut toujours voir la misère que vivent la population noire, les descendants des esclaves.
Quand on voit le nombre de milliardaires et de millionnaires blancs qu'il y a et le nombre de milliardaires noirs, on voit la différence qu'il y a et qui continue.
C'est pas ça qui a changé. Donc il faut exiger un vrai changement. Ce que les américains ont changé,
ce qu'il se passe généralement dans les changements de chefs d'état où quand on passe d'u parti à l'autre actuellement,
c'est qu'on change seulement l'écran. Or les virus... Parce que ce que l'on voit nous dans l'ordinateur, c'est l'écran.
Le virus, il n'est pas dans l'écrand'un ordinateur, quand on garde le disque dur, quand on garde le même environnement,
et qu'on change l'écran, on a rien fait. il faut un changement radical.
Je ne peut pas vivre, je ne peut pas envisager ma vie sans avoir un combat noble.
Vivre pour manger, boire, baiser, c'est pas une vie pour moi.
OK c'est important, les plaisir dans la vie c'est important, mais je dois avoir une mission noble, je dois avoir un grand projet
pour continuer à me battre, pour continuer à apprécier d'être sur cette terre.
Donc j'ai besoin d'un projet comme el Nowheristan. Même si sa réalisation ne va... Je ne vais pas voir la réalisation du projet
mais au moins, j'ai le plaisir, de me dire chaque fois que je suis un peu déprimé, chaque fois que je suis aggressé par des gens
verbalement ou que je reçois des insultes de les haters, que je me sens menacé, de dire "ça vaut la peine"
Je suis en train de faire quelque chose, de mettre un train sur les rails et ce train peut mener l'humanité vers quelque chose de beau.
Vers ces lendemains qui chantent, vers un monde meilleur. Et je suis convaincu de ce projet.
C'est pas une vision que j'ai eue, c'est pas un archange qui est venu me visiter la nuit, c'est aps des voix que j'ai entendues,
c'est basé sur une espérience personnelle, une lutte qui a commencé il y a 30 ans quand j'avais 15 ans.
C'est des souffrances, la sofrfance de perdre des amis, de voir des amis tomber devant soi. C'est des années d'exil,
C'est la somme de tout ça qui m'a permis de penser la philosophie et le système du Nowheristan.
Je sais que ça va apporter un grand bienfait à toute l'humanité et avec la globalisation maintenant,
on ne peut plus parler du bien-être d'une partie de l'humanité et pas de l'autre.
Parce que ça va générer des jaloux, le voyage est très facile, l'internet est là, faire des bombes...
Donc s'il n'y a pas une répartition des richesses, s'il n'y a pas une répartition du bonheur, du bien-être, il y aura les pauvres qui vont venir un jour rendre visite aux riches.
Quand l'argent ne va pas vers les pauvres, c'est les pauvres qui vont vers l'argent.
Un voisinage, les quartiers défavorisés, s'ils ont faim, ils sortent et viennent dans les bons quartiers pour casser la porte et ouvrir le réfrigérateur.
Et ça c'est à l'échelle planétaire maintenant. Avant, les crève-la-faim ne savaient pas comment vivent les autres.
Mais maintenant, dans la dernière des dernières favellas, dans le dernier des derniers quartiers populaires d'un pays arabe,
ils ont des satellites, ils voient à quoi les autres ont accès et ce qu'eux n'ont pas.
Il y aura toujours des riches et des pauvres mais ce ne sera pas dû à la naissance, ce n'est pas comme un loto.
Quand on est maintenant en Suisse, même si on est idiot et paresseux, on sait qu'on va vivre mieux qu'un génie qui nait dans quelque pays africain ou pays défavorisé.
J'ai un message pour les français et non pas pour le gouvernement français, je pense que c'est inutile de parler à des gens qui savent bien que
qu'ils font de mauvaises choses mais ils sont aveuglés par le gain, par les intérêts financiers. Donc ça ne sert à rien.
Avec ses gens-là il ne faut même pas dialoguer, ces gens-là il faut les punir, les forcer à changer de politique parce que...
On débat avec des gens qi ont une idéologie différente, avec des gens qui sont dans leur tort parce qu'ils n'ont pas compris des choses.
Mais quelqu'un, un mafieux, qui sait que ce qu'il fait est mauvais, c'est pas le peine de lui dire "non il faut pas faire ça" il le sait déjà.
C'est peine perdue. Pour les français je vais leur dire de ne pas se perdre dans les détails. De ne pas sacrifier l'ensemble pour le détail.
Donc tous leurs débats et tous ces clivages qui n'ont plus aucun sens de droite et de gauche, parce que maintenant,
je ne suis pas de très près la politique française mais quand je vois parler un politicien français, je ne sais vraiment plus s'il est de droite ou de gauche.
Et pourtant on continue à coller ces étiquettes. Je vois parfois maintenant des disours des gens de l'extrême droite,
qui s'apparentent vraiment... On peut penser que ce sont des "cocos" des communistes. Je vois des communistes, c'est l'extrême droite.
Donc il ne faut plus penser avec ces termes, il faut refonder la politique française, il faut refonder la politique européenne, il faut refonder la politique mondiale.
La France a une place à occuper dans le panorama mondial. La culture française est l'une des plus grande cultures du monde.
La renaissance française, le siècle des lumières, le rayonnement de la France ne doit pas cesser.
La France doit revenir à ce qui a fait sa grandeur. A ce qui a fait que la culture française a inspiré plein de révolutions dans le monde.
Ce qui a fait que cette culture a toujours été celle des révolutionnaires, celle des gens qui veulent faire évoluer des sociétés laïques.
La laïcité est un concept qui est très important et la France a une place de choix dans la promotion de la laïcité.
Cela doit être fait à travers la culture. La vraie culture, pas celle des Bernard-Henri Lévy et d'autres clowns
qui sont les chouchous des média pour plein de raisons. Donc... Je suis vraiment triste quand je vois ce qu'il se passe.
J'espère, je crois en la force du peuple français qui a fait l'une des plus belles révolutions et qui a aussi fait d'autres révolutions culturelles...
Quand je vois l'esprit qu'il y avait, les écrits qu'il y avait, les graffitis de Mai 68. Quand je vois la solidarité que la France a su montrer
pour des causes comme la révolution cubaine ou bien comme Allende au Chili, le vrai 11 Septembre,
je me dis que ça ne peut pas s'évaporer, ce n'est pas aussi loin que ça.
Je pense qu'il y a un problème aussi dans le système éducatif en France, parce que mes enfants sont au lycée français donc
quand je les vois rarement parce qu'ils ne vivent pas au Liban et que je vois ce qu'ils leur apprennent, je me dis que c'est triste aussi qu'il y a
des choses que... Quand les pédagogues font des erreurs ce sont des générations entières qui sont sacrifiées.
Il faut revenir un peu aux bonnes... C'est pas très progressiste ce que je vais dire pour quelqu'un qui l'a toujours été...
Mais parfois il y a de bonnes vielles méthodes qui sont en train d'être perdues, que beaucoup de laxisme n'a jamais créé de grandeur,
que rien dans ce monde n'a été créé avec des fainéants, avec des gens qui n'ont pas envie de se lever tôt, qui n'ont pas envie de se battre, qui ne voient pas grand.
Viva la revolucion comme dit... Petite démonstration.
Il ne faut pas avoir recours aux armes, c'est le dernier recours, c'est pas ... Caca, c'est pas quelque chose qu'il faut faire.